People seem to love stuff like bungee jumping
and sky-diving.
But what draws us to these scary life-threatening
experiences?
Why do we want to jump off of stuff?
On May 16, 2015, Dean Potter, a celebrated
extreme sportsman, and a fellow climber, Graham
Hunt; jumped off a 7,500 foot (2,285m) cliff
in Yosemite National Park with the goal of
wingsuit flying through the rocky cliffs before
parachuting to safety.
Both men crashed while trying to fly through
an outcropping and were found dead many hours
later.
BASE jumping is an acronym for buildings,
antennas, spans (such as bridges) and Earth
(cliffs and mountaintops) -- all places to
jump from while wearing a wingsuit, parachute
or both.
At least 257 people have died BASE jumping
to date, according to a major BASE jumping
forum; and Potter, who was a major enthusiast
for outdoor "extreme" sports, called BASE
jumping and free-climbing, "death-consequence"
activities.
Aren't we all programmed to survive?
Why do we risk death for a thrill?
More than 800 people have died climbing the
mountains of Nepal -- including Everest,;
442 from skydiving from 1998 to 2014 - and
even scuba-diving sees about 80 deaths annually.
I mean, skateboarding had 30 deaths in 2012!
Psychologists believe we perform risky behaviors
because of our fear response, and medical
researchers believe it has to do with the
brain's reward systems; though both are true.
In a small study from the Queensland University
of Technology in Australia; researchers explored
the psychological result of fear responses
in extreme sports participants.
Fear is an important inborn response to perceived
danger.
Your body's top priority is to preserve itself;
fear is a way to motivate it to do so.
But for some people, overcoming fear was a
meaningful and constructive event in their
lives.
They still EXPERIENCE fear, but it's not seen
as a negative, but rather, a positive experience.
Potter wrote specifically, and poetically,
about his experiences with fear, and how overcoming
that fear was transformative for him.
Unfortunately, that's not easily translatable
for a general population -- instead we can
only look at how the chemicals in our brains
surrounding fear go on to affect our behavior.
When jumping out of an airplane or free-climbing
up a cliff, an almond-shaped set of neurons
in our brain called the amygdala releases
hormones which quicken the heart, hone the
senses and prepare your body to flee or fight.
During this fear response, our brains' reward
center releases large amounts of dopamine.
Studies have shown, dopamine, a powerful reward
chemical for our bodies, is also connected
to the recollection of terror.
It's released when we eat, exercise, or talk
to our friends and family, and reinforces
those healthy behaviors by making us feel
good about doing those things.
But, massive dopamine release is associated
with drug use, and addiction; which is how
extreme athletes and enthusiasts are often
associated with junkies or addicts.
Extreme athletes provoke this fear response
in themselves, experiencing the fear of death,
and enjoying the natural-high they get from
the dopamine release that follows.
The problem is, the brain can get used to
high-levels of dopamine, and thus, more extreme
events may have to be performed to simply
enjoy day-to-day life.
This is called sensation-seeking behavior;
language created to describe heavy-use drug
addicts.
A 2004 study compared ecstasy-users to bungee-jumpers
and found similar sensation-seeking brain
chemistry.
The reason people continue to do these activities,
aside from them being fun and making them
feel good, is once their brain gets acclimated
to higher levels of dopamine, it's difficult
to wean it off.
Like an addict, the brain craves MORE dopamine
to feel the same high.
In the end, the risk and reward are real,
and people can alter their brain chemistry
to get a "natural high" from things like BASE
jumping.
But I'm not trying to condemn people who seek
out sensations.
Sure, Dean Potter participated in dangerous
behaviors, but he ALSO inspired people all
over the globe to explore their planet first-hand;
to get off their couches and into their National
Parks; into their world, and to try their
hand at things they may not have otherwise.
Extreme sports can extend to long-distance
races like marathons or ultra-marathons; but
this man is 104 and still runs races.
So they can't be THAT dangerous, right?
Seeker Daily reveals a man who just won't
quit running (soundup) Thanks for watching
DNews, get out there and do something today.